[Music]  after that I took part in a competition  I was selected to come here Brussels say  I wanted to talk to the Ministry of  Education I am here to represent  secondary students from all around  Europe and to make their voices be heard  so has to be a place that this happiness  before today I wish that we do not give  so much importance to it and much we can  give importance just what we are open  don't you agree that's giving everybody  any good friend make the world a better  place here commissioner and ministers  one of my dream is to become minister of  education because the Minister of  Education has the care of oil sizzling  in the pan  being a mother myself the main message  was sponsored this more family-friendly  measures and to listen more to the  students because each student has their  different needs  I believe that if they hear our voices  more students would go back to education  and to get heard the Constitution  [Music]  [Applause]